[Music]
but i think it's safe to say
[Music]
can you
they are a platinum selling group with
multiple grammys and their latest album
recently debuted on the billboard 200 at
number seven and number two
on billboard's top album sales chart
their second top ten of their career and
they're performing tonight in las vegas
it's joel and luke from king from before
king and country welcome you guys nice
to see you
guys the new album i was just telling
you off the air so good what are you
waiting for
what are you waiting for
where did you guys come up with that
title question yeah i love it it's funny
we sort of said that the album is
three parts it's a it's a global record
with kind of the backdrop of
what america's walk through what the
world walked through frankly with the
pandemic um it's a family record a lot
of a lot of songs about either our
parents or siblings or our wives and
then it's inherently a spiritual album
uh as well and i think the question what
are we waiting for could be answered in
a thousand different ways and that's
sort of the point of music right it's
like it it reads differently
in association with your story like i'm
waiting for
the moment when i'm not waiting for
something oh that's like
that's my
yeah see what i did there yeah well you
mentioned that it's inspired by a lot of
family members and people you know the
song unsung hero on there is about your
parents
can you tell me a little bit about that
story well uh for those of you don't
know our story is is we came from
australia originally born austria come
to america as very young boys i'm very
confused very confused australian
american accent and when you realize you
know as you get older you actually start
to realize wow my parents did a lot
early that is it's an unexpected story
my dad virtually started his life over
at 40 with six kids and another on the
way
and you start to realize that who are
the people that kind of made some of
these things happen i mean we all
married american girls you know we so if
it wasn't for some of their
faith in the idea of what america could
look like to to risk it all we wouldn't
be here and so essentially i think with
this recording of this album we were
looking back and saying man our mother
our father they are some of the greatest
unsung heroes that we've we've ever met
but they're not the ones you know doing
the interviews like this they're the
ones behind the scenes our dad is a bit
of a sung hero though
i love that you guys said you're married
to american women can you guys do an
american accent
well mercedes i'd just like to say it's
really great to be here with you in the
studio thanks so much for having us nice
i end up sounding like an american
president
thanks so much vote for me las vegas
accent but i can't do a real normal
accent i just can do the kind of country
thing we're so happy you guys are here
you guys got to check it out for king
and country performing at the orleans
arena tonight
so talented you guys gotta run and go do
the show hey this is funny
this is a fun fact being in vegas i have
dubbed uh our show sort of the
australian version of a cirque du soleil
show that's right because we've got
streamers we're flying things are moving
and so you have to come tonight to judge
for yourself it's going to be a great
show thank you guys for joining us it's
so good to see you jillian over to you
well